Taylor Swift is single in the city New
York has been an important landscape and
location for the Story of My Life in the
last couple of years the singer was
spotted in the Big Apple on Monday night
grabbing dinner with her friend and
longtime collaborator Jack Antonoff and
his fiance Margaret Qualley just days
after news broke of Taylor split from
boyfriend Joe Alwyn I would always like
to keep people on their toes that's
Taylor looking gorge in a black
off-the-shoulder top bedazzled Jeans by
area a silver Paco Rabanne purse and her
signature red lip that color is a really
bold color that to me represents really
bold emotions the Grammy winner dined at
Italian Restaurant Via corota which fun
fact is just blocks away from Cornelia
Street you know the street that inspired
one of Taylor's songs on her lover album
which fans think is about Joe
[Music]
of course this is the first time Taylor
has been seen in public since E.T
exclusively learned that the couple
called it quits after six years of
dating a source explaining that the
breakup was amicable and not dramatic
the relationship had just run its course
and the source says that's why Joe
hasn't been spotted at any of Taylor's
shows they're also really heavy
pressures that come with this life and
you just have to try to balance them
Taylor is currently on her era's World
Tour and some swifties think the singer
alluded to the breakup by switching up
her set list in Arlington Texas on March
31st instead of Performing Invisible
String which is thought to be a love
song about her relationship with Joe
[Music]
invisible
tying you to me
[Music]
she played the one a breakup track
both songs are off her 2020 album
folklore where Taylor and Joe famously
collaborated under the actor pseudonym
William Bowery there's been a lot of
discussion about William Bowery and his
identity because
it's not a real person so William Bowery
is Joe
as we know the next stop on Taylor's
tour is Tampa Florida and one thing's
for sure swifties will be ready and
waiting to spot any and all Easter eggs
that hint at a split
[Music]